and another anniversary the santa claus
turns
25. e.t was on set with tim allen eric
lloyd and
their favorite reindeer comet
he's making a list tracking it twice
elves reindeer and of course jolly kris
kringle take center stage in the beloved
christmas comedy the santa claus which
made its theater debut in
1994.
how do i look nice and e.t was on set of
the holiday classic when alan put on
that red suit for the very first time
go down the chimney go down the chimney
do a strange guy's house with a bag of
toys
in my underwear no
gotta put the suit on first allen plays
scott calvin who inadvertently takes on
the role of santa claus after the
existing saint nick perishes from an
unfortunate rooftop slip
[Music]
the film also stars a then
eight-year-old eric lloyd who plays
allen's son
charlie my dad is santa claus
the movie's about a little boy and his
dad
that aren't very close and
[Music]
one night they go on great adventure to
the north pole
and they start to know each other
um better during the year as the year
pass
and then they get to the next christmas
and they're very close what we're
shooting is after
he becomes santa it's the first booth we
landed on
so it's the roof we've got here and
yeah yeah let's go rules about flying
reindeer there's only so many of them
available being the ones that claws uses
and they don't usually lend them out
so we couldn't use the real reindeer we
all had two of them
comet and blitzen had to tell all the
other rangers how to fly and they got
this union problem
and it turns out those lifelike reindeer
with allen and lloyd on the roof were
actually
animatronic the main thing that that we
were all striving for was to create a
character
not just an animal but someone that
would react to tim allen and
interact with him as well this is comet
he is the lead
reindeer of santa's sleigh team and he's
got a little bit of an attitude
he initially doesn't care for tim allen
as the new santa at all but they they
kind of become friends towards the end
of the film
easy rudolph
excuse me comment stick around e.t
tim's going to take us to the north pole
right
that's the north pole we're flying back
and forth between the north pole
and hollywood and toronto and locations
and i said you you wait you shoot
something you wait
do you make the toys no stupid the owls
do
bobby we don't say stupid and we don't
say elves
they're little people no but they really
are
elves whatever honey we're in the
wrapping room right now because
most the elves are gone we are the only
the first group ever to allow
a film crew at the north pole so you're
gonna see stuff you've never seen before
the work goes a lot of packages have
been wrapped and these guys are furious
little rappers
a lot of the country's most famous rap
groups have come
from here hi bernard hi a sport
hey daddy called me sports like you
wonderful
and here's another little movie fun fact
while filming
lloyd lost his actual teeth forcing
filmmakers to improvise
when i lost my piece um i was already
doing the movie
so they had to put these in to replace
snaps like that what does that mean it
means you put on the suit you're the big
guy
so how did allen transform into santa
claus does this look like a little
weight to you
the biggest thing was trying to keep
maintaining tim's look and his
personality through his eyes and as much
of his face as we could show
i'm in big trouble when we got to our
design
stages we started with with tim allen as
he as he actually is
did some sketches and he undergoes
obviously stages of transformation and
at this stage we've given him the buzz
cut which is the uh
what we've been calling the working
class santa look allen had to wear
layers of thick body suits to bring his
character to life
and he told et back in 1994 that his
transformation was not
an easy process he had to glue this
thing to my skin
and the thing weighed 60 pounds so just
it pulled on every part of me and it
actually
actually ripped little fissures in my
shoulders this was after
14 hours and the other makeup they'd
take it off and then put this new makeup
back on i was not a very
i was not a very nice santa it was kind
of a fun thing a nice jux position to
see me sitting in a chair and
the kids are coming like get away from
me
and then on screen you go oh name
per noel babo natalie
pair's nicole toppo jijo
even all that discomfort did not stop
him from reprising his role as santa in
the film's
two-hit sequels the santa claus 2 and
the santa claus 3
the escape clause you helped make me
santa
and now 26 years later those three
holiday classics are still
christmas time staples the first time
i've seen it and i cried just because
it's great
if you're a fool i'm a film buff yeah
it's really remarkable to see you know
i'm in a film and the process took so
long it was really
really exciting merry christmas to all
and to all a good night
when i wake up i'm getting a cat scan
[Music]